if you want to hear about a kids movie
clown that scarred an entire generation
stick around to the end of this video so
we've talked about horror movie clowns
I've written you a creepy clown story
and short film and it kind of begs the
question are there ever any actual funny
clowns who aren't just horrifying I can
only really think of one but why are so
many people afraid of clowns maybe
they're just naturally scary because the
makeup of the clown often contrasts and
hides their true facial expressions
tapping into the fear of the unknown
kind of similar to the fear of the dark
but maybe it's a deep-seated fear
planted from the point of childhood
because if you look at some of the many
clowns seen in kids movies there are
some really disturbing ones and most of
them come from old Disney movies like
Dumbo from 1941 this movie is about a
circus elephant so you can bet there are
a lot of clowns
but there's one scene in particular that
stands out Dumbo has a dream about this
parade of pink elephants which are
already kind of creepy with their empty
eye sockets and Fauvism inspired art
style so when they start to appear as
clowns things quickly break down into an
acid trip nightmare
[Music]
and as kind of a side note I always
think the title at the end of the movie
is also pretty messed up I mean look at
that guy
it looks like he's crawling out from
behind that gong to feast on you of
course this is kind of an older movie so
I think that adds to the creep factor a
little bit another circus clown
appearance can be seen in Reds dream a
Pixar short film from 1987 this is one
of the earliest CG animated films about
a unicycle who dreams of being in the
circus and what makes this so disturbing
is the level of detail and quality of
animation isn't quite what we're used to
today
it's just off-putting seeing this
clown's deformed face and the way those
balls float in the air is unnatural
there's something off about the music
that is before the music just stops and
he looks directly into the camera that's
just so creepy the ending of this is
really depressing for a Pixar film too
the dream ends and the unicycle just
cries in the corner for almost 30
seconds and then it just ends this clown
also makes a little cameo in Toy Story 2
another Pixar clown appeared more
recently in 2015 with inside out when
two of Riley's emotions joy and sadness
try to sneak in the part of her brain
that contains her biggest fears the only
thing scarier than a creepy clown is a
giant creepy clown jingles seems to have
been a birthday party clown that
psychologically scorned Riley what makes
him terrifying and similar to what makes
Pennywise so unnerving which is the fact
that he's crazy and unpredictable and
did I mention giant this movie is more
recent so I wasn't a kid when it came
out but if I had been I'm sure my
nightmares would have been filled with
that one
Oh
speaking of nightmare clowns how did
this make it into a kids movie a lot of
kids are already afraid of going to the
doctor so the fact that pee-wee's big
adventure then takes that fear and
throws clowns into the mix is not gonna
go over well for them not to mention
they seem to be using torture devices to
fix this bike and the whole dream
devolves into some kind of nightmarish
hellscape
[Music]
[Music]
and moving right along from one
nightmare to another who could forget
the clown with the tearaway face from
Nightmare Before Christmas the fact that
the clown's true face is just a black
void is so disturbing compared to the
other characters who simply have a
spooky form like a skeleton or a
boogeyman it's not a scary movie despite
being about Halloween but a clown with a
black void under his face has become
known as one of the scariest parts for
people who watch this as kids but the
90s clown horror does not end there
Air Bud of all things has a crazy clown
in it like jangles it's the psychopathic
tendencies from a birthday clown that
get you here as soon as you see this
rusty clown truck come barreling over
the hill at the start of the movie you
know it means trouble outside of the
crudely applied makeup one thing that
puts you on edge about this guy is the
evidence of anger issues he's a bit less
scary than some of the others i've
mentioned because of his clumsiness but
there's still something off-putting
about a birthday clown who hates kids
there are also hints of alcoholism which
can turn anyone into a monster and the
fact that it's happening to a clown it
makes it that much worse the next one is
from a TV show not a film but since are
you afraid of the dark is an anthology
series it could really be considered
more of a collection of short films so
I'm gonna count it yeah what kind of
strange stuff happened inside the ride
well that's what the kids wanted to know
especially
and also it is intended to be scary to
kids but you know what it's my channel I
can do what I want I'm talking about it
Zeebo the clown is from an episode
called the tale of laughing in the dark
Zeebo is actually the ghost of a runaway
circus clown whose cigarette butt
started the fire that ended his life
while hiding out in an amusement park
spook house this one definitely has the
coolest backstory and I always love some
good creepy clown music Zeebo plays more
on suspense than it does shock value we
don't actually see the real ghost of
Zeebo only this disturbing prop but when
josh steals the clown's nose to prove
his bravery Zeebo definitely begins to
haunt him at home it's never fully
revealed if Z Bo's ghost can be seen or
if this creepy carny who can be seen
smoking at the end is actually the ghost
of Zeebo out of makeup one thing's for
sure I wouldn't want to hear this clowns
laughter in the dark and finally we have
the creepiest clown to grace the screen
of a kids movie have you noticed that
four out of the seven clowns so far have
appeared in nightmares that's probably
not a coincidence this last one is no
exception it comes from the 1987 Disney
movie The Brave Little Toaster a movie
about five household appliances looking
for their old master a movie that has no
business being this creepy just roll
[Music]
[Music]
if they were trying to ruin every kid's
childhood they got the design of this
guy right he just looked sinister you
may have seen youtuber colossal is crazy
to repurpose this image to be his logo
the clown himself may actually be a
reference to the firefighter clowns from
Dumbo although this is much scarier
everything from the lighting to the
voice to the towering perspective makes
this clown the stuff of every kid's
nightmare and to top it all off
Disney always has to have a dark side
and the suicide references suggested by
the imagery of a fork in the toaster or
a toaster in the bathtub make this scene
absolutely chilling and that's before
you even get to the sound of this clowns
creepy sadistic Wow
if any of these clowns left a mark on
your childhood be sure to give this
video a like and go down in the comments
and let me know about any other creepy
things you've seen in kids movies if
you're interested in topics like this
check out some of my other creepy things
videos and remember to subscribe to see
these worlds for new Horrors every week
winged the death pen for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one and
zooming we both survived